Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right, what's going on?
And guys, this is Rob and we are picking back up again with, uh, venom beyond,
right?
And this is basically the start of the King and block and you guys will see what
I'm talking about. Once we get towards the end of this,
this is basically where King and black begins, right?
So I'm really excited about this.
And I think that what we might do sometime this week as part of a lead up to the
whole King and black thing,
is we might take all of Donnie Cates venom run and just kind of condense it down
into a full story. We'll call it like part one,
or like the canned black lead-up or something along those lines.
But something to indicate,
this is all the stuff that you need to know going into like the King and block.
But this basically picks up again with this alternate reality that we're in
earth, 10 51, whereby you have Dylan, this alternate reality version of any,
I'm sorry,
this alternate reality version of the son of Eddie Brock who basically conquered
the world and where Matt Gargan had been sent to the forces of Eddie for the
purpose of basically taking them down,
that he also operates as a kind of spy of sorts, right.
That Dylan can see through his symbionts.
But what we ended up seeing was that like the previous video scorpion was
essentially defeated.
And so this all kind of coincides with Dr. Octopus showing up to, to Dylan,
like codex, we'll call them codex for the sake of keeping this video simple,
instead of talking about two different versions of Dylan,
but he runs up on codex and he basically tells him that they've reverse
engineered the armor that scorpion wore when he was initially going after Eddie
Brock and using the name virus and that,
because this armor is based on the war machine, Mark three model,
it was created by Tony stark for James Rhodes. It includes,
what's basically automated environment scanning technology,
which essentially means that it scans the environment and then record the
environment. And this kind of confirms the statement of,
of scorpion to Kodak's when he was initially captured that he came from an
alternate reality.
But what's more important about this is that when it comes to alternate
realities and Marvel comics, you have, what's kind of,
what's been referred to historically as a kind of quantum frequency basically,
meaning that each individual universe has its own range more or less. Right?
So the way I like to use it as we talked about music, right?
So we say like the main Marvel universe is the key of C and the ultimate
universe might be like key. You know,
it might be like C sharp or something like that.
But if the main Marvel universe is in the key of C,
then what this means is that in order to access the main Marvel universe,
your quantum signal, or, or your ability to, to create a portal,
it means you have to resonate at the key of C as well, right?
So that's what this suit basically does.
This suit will at least accessing this suit and being able to reverse engineer,
it would allow Otto Octavius to in effect,
recreate a portal that would allow them to access the main Marvel universe.
And with his intelligence, it would only take them about two weeks to do.
And so the idea is get to work on it, right?
Because it means there'll be more worlds for Dylan to conquer. Essentially,
at that point, you switch over to, uh,
the underground laboratory of Reed Richards in this alternate reality,
the crazy Reed Richards, who's basically kind of talking to scorpion tonight,
Gargan,
and he really just kind of reiterated everything that we were already told.
And it's kinda nuts because there was, uh, an Ironman in this, and of course,
much like the main Marvel universe, Reed, Richards and Ironman were friends,
meaning that he's well-versed and, and, you know, starts technology.
The problem with this is that he's also insane. And so his response is, yes,
I can rebuild that gape, but it'll take me like five years to do,
but it'll take me like five years to do that because the resources are
exceedingly limited. If they have like all the resources available out there,
then sure. They'd be able to do it though,
between his insanity and a lack of resources, they simply just can't.
And so you have this moment here where they talk about the idea of going back
and then the response of Dylan is, but I don't want to,
the reason why is because Dylan never knew his mom,
but he never knew Anne Wayne.
And so being in this alternate reality where he meets her for the first time,
it makes sense. He doesn't want to go back. Right.
It makes sense that he doesn't want to leave anymore,
that he wants to stay here. He never knew his mom.
And so he's always wanting to get to know his mom.
He's now in a situation where he can, why would he want to give that up?
It's everything he ever wanted. And so with that being the case,
it's almost like he's kind of being forced, right?
Polled ripped away from this life that he wants so dearly.
And so with that being the case,
and just kind of realizes that it's turning into a kind of sentimental moment
and Anne has still not gotten over the fact that her son in this universe,
this reality, his version of Dylan became a bad guy, or he became codex.
He conquered the world and killed pretty much everybody that she cared about and
turn them into symbionts. And so she basically like tells everybody get out,
right? Everybody's got to go,
everybody go rest tomorrow where we're taking this water, my son right now,
it all kind of comes to a head when you've got, you know,
Anne doing her thing because she can't sleep.
And then Dylan shows up and the two of them have this very kind of sentimental
moment.
And the reason for that is because whenever codex came across her Symbion or
tried to contact her Semia, she would burn. But with Dylan,
from the main Marvel universe, that doesn't happen.
And the reason for that is because much like we've seen with like something like
the infinity gauntlet, which only works in its native universe,
Dylan codex can only control symbionts in his own universe.
And so any Symbion or any being this attached to symbionts outside of this
universe, codex cannot control.
And that's the reason why when Dylan approaches and weighing,
because he's from the main Marvel universe, he does not affect her.
Symbion in the same way he could hug her. He and he could interact with her.
He could treat her like a mom. And that's kind of what he says. Right. You know,
he says like, you know, when this is all said and done, like,
I don't really want to leave. I don't really want to go.
But if we do have to go back to my universe, then come with me, right? Like,
come with us, be my mom in that universe. It's a very touching moment, right?
This is especially touching. If you know the history of Anne Wayne,
how tragic her story's been over the years,
or at least was until they killed her off. I mean, it's, it's a very,
very intriguing thing to see here. And it's really, really cool as,
so what this does is kind of, you know,
really inspire a kind of renewed vigor inside of ant and the sense that she
realizes she can't run away from who our sons become,
why she can't run away from the fact that her son has become codex,
that her son has done terrible things. It's not necessarily to say that she has,
but it's kind of the impression that's being put off here is that historically
speaking, when it comes to her son, codex, sure.
She's been fighting the good fight,
but she's also been dreading the time at which she would actually have to take
him down. And this moment realizing that the man, her son could have become,
and if he can be saved, the man, he can still become,
then there's all the incentive in the world to kind of leave that fear and that
anxiety behind and travel head fast into facing off against this guy.
And that's exactly what they do.
The other part of this is that codex comes to the realization. Of course,
the one that we already realized that he cannot control the CMBS from alternate
realities, either much like Peter Parker and venom, he also can't detect them.
And so that's kind of the funny thing is that for him,
whenever he tries to reach out and detect the Symbion of Eddie Brock,
the venoms to be at this attached to him, he can't pick up on it, right?
Because it's not from his universe. And so, as they're,
they're kind of in the middle of all this,
and as auto Octavius is continuing to work on this, this portal of sorts,
there's a kind of an alarm that comes in and it's basically a unmanned aircraft.
That's basically heading towards the location.
And when Ottawa Octavia says that there's no life forms on board,
that's when it dawns on codex know there's life forms there,
but it's the venom Symbion right.
The one that I can't pick up and this thing comes cruising in and just smashes
right inside the ceiling of this place,
right from there and waves like everybody get in and they all go flooding into
that place. Right? Attacking everybody. They can now right off the bat,
Donnie Cates gives us codex versus venom. And it's a cool thing to see,
because this is basically like Spider-Man fighting venom, right?
Spiderman cannot detect the venom Symbian and that's one of the things that
makes venom so deadly for Spiderman, much like this here,
codex can not control the venom Sindia.
And so he's facing off against a very powerful person relative to himself who
Symbion, he cannot dominate and this fight ends incredibly fast. Right?
And that's one of the big differences here.
That's kind of the big weakness of codex is that you would look at him and you
would say, okay,
but a person who is able to conquer the world using symbionts surely he'd be
able to overtake venom, but there's a big difference here.
Eddie Brock has fought time and time again,
as venom with the Symbion facing off against a multitude of enemies.
The codex seemingly has not that I wouldn't go as far as to say that he rested
on his laurels while the world was being conquered.
But there's a difference between fighting some heavy hitting superheroes by
yourself and fighting a whole bunch of heavy hitting superheroes with hundreds
of symbionts at your side,
it really kind of diminishes what your accomplishments are.
It diminishes what it is that he could actually do, because for the most part,
he didn't really do it on his own. And so in response to that,
he basically calls him the entirety of the Avengers team.
They all come pouring in, right? All these Symbion Avengers guys.
And then while that's going on,
Gargan basically sneaks off grabs his virus suit. And in the moment,
when you have any Brock who seizes control of codex for the purpose of defeating
him, they would, he ends up,
continue to do is actually half his symbiotic bond itself, directly to codex.
And then in turn, show him this life that he could have had, right.
A kind of shared memory that's when virus mixes attack, right?
Not Gargan shows up or the most inconvenient time and starts attacking,
you know, Eddie Brock and basically says like,
you're going to take me back to prison once we get back there and that's not
going to happen either, I'm going to have my vengeance here,
or I'm not going to have it at all. But in the midst of his whole attack,
suddenly he shot in the back by Reed Richards,
who would basically use the technology of Tony stark to take down the war
machine suit. Right. So garden's, tight-knit, you know,
completely out of the picture, what this does is it leads to, uh,
to Eddie Brock being able to subdue codex yet again,
and then codex actually starts reaching out directly to, uh, to Dylan. Right.
And what this does is it allows a, of shared memory state,
and the sense of it's all the things that Dylan can basically pass through his
mother, uh,
and all the things she can pass through to him in terms of the life that he
always wanted to have with her, the life she always wanted to have with him.
And then Eddie Brock's memories of the life he had with his son,
bonding them all together. And when that happens,
codex gets a vision of what his life could have looked like.
They all kind of do, to be honest,
like it's really Eddie and it's and it's Dylan, and it's an weighing and it's,
uh, it's codex all kind of experiencing this joint memory of how life could have
been, how fantastic it could have been. But because of the decisions of codex,
it never happened that in the fact that that Eddie Brock took his own life,
those never came to fruition. And so because of that,
codex is completely overwhelmed by the experience.
But in turn basically gets rid of all the symbionts, right.
He just stops his influence over them and stops and kind of comes back to his
normal self. Now,
the other part of this seems to be that Knoll had an exceedingly strong grip
on Dylan, on codex. And so when this whole sort of short,
a shared memory took place and actually released him from the influence of Knoll
and kind of returned him back to his normal self,
but regardless of how you slice it, he's basically back to being a good guy.
Now, the problem is that he falls into, what's essentially a catatonic state,
right? So you jump forward by about a year or so.
And this is a pretty significant moment that in all this time that they've been
here, you have Dylan,
you have any Brock and you have Anne who have all just basically been spending
time together as a family,
the way that they always imagine themselves doing this,
that is basically a pretty chill world. And the response of all this. I mean,
I'm sure you probably have some small time criminals, but nothing too crazy,
but nothing too outrageous instead,
it's basically just them kind of enjoying their lives. And so, because of that,
there's always kind of looming on the horizon,
this idea that they're all going to have to go back, right.
That they're going to have to go back to their universe.
And so about a few months after that, with Dr. Octopus,
having had the absolute tar beat out of him by Reed to the point that he
actually started giving him information on how to build this thing,
that the portal's effectively finished,
but Anne is actually going to stay behind because with her son, her son, Dylan,
you know, I guess formerly codex now, Dylan kind of back in a catatonic state,
but also demonstrating that he basically, you know,
came back to being a good guy, right?
That he's more or less cured for lack of a better word that she's going to wait
until he reawakens and then try to nurse him back into, you know,
kind of having a normal life here, but for, for Dylan himself and for, uh,
for Eddie, of course,
they go back to the main Marvel universe where the King and block and everything
kicks off. And this is, what's really kind of interesting here.
It looks like a year has actually passed in the main Marvel universe as well.
And the reason why this matters is because with this one year time jump in that
period, no seems to have come back, right?
No return you return to in the main Marvel universe.
And the reason that the reason why we know this is because when they get back
there, all the stars are gone. There's nothing out there,
but absolute blackness that no has officially returned and is already
gone. The process of conquering the main Marvel universe with that being said,
guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the rod port.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like,
and that will catch you off.
[Inaudible].